here's an interesting problem involving
perimeter from the 2000 American
Invitational mathematics exam so it says
the diagram shows a rectangle that has
been dissected into nine overlapping
squares one two three four five six
seven eight nine overlapping squares
given that the width and the height of
the rectangle are positive integers with
greatest common divisor one so they're
talking about the width and the height
of the rectangle the reason why they're
saying greatest common divisor one is
they're saying that you can't that they
don't have a common divisor that you can
divide them both by to get kind of a
more simplified ratio and to think about
that is we might be faced with two
choices one where maybe it's this side
over here is let me draw it like this
five and 15 but over here our greatest
common divisor isn't one we have they're
both divisible by five over here so what
you'd want to do is say no instead of
five and fifteen they need to be one and
three now you have the same ratio of
sides but now the greatest common
divisor is one you kind of have it in
the simplified form or the most
simplified form if you divide both of
both of this this height and this width
by five so that's why they're saying
greatest common divisor one and then
they say find the perimeter of the
rectangle so let's see what we can do
here so any card you to pause it and try
to do it on your own before I bumble my
way through this problem so let's start
in the beginning let's start at the
square right over here the center square
and they did tell us that there are all
squares so let's say that that square
right over here has as a length X and a
height X it's an X by X square so let me
write it so this is an X and that is an
X so this is an X by X square right over
there and then you have this square
right over here and we don't know its
measurements so let's say that this
square right over here is y by y Y by Y
so it has Y width and it also has Y
height now what is this square over here
well this is an X plus y by an X plus y
square because the the width of these
squares combined made the width of this
larger square so what I'm going to do is
I'm actually going to actually this
might be an easier way to write since
these are all squares I'm going to write
the dimension of that square inside the
square so this is going to be an X by X
square kind of a non-conventional
notation but it'll help us keep things a
little bit neat this is going to be a Y
by Y square so I'm not saying the area
is why I'm saying it's Y by Y this over
here is going to be an X plus y times an
X and X plus y is going to be each of
its dimension so it's going to be X plus
y height and X plus y width then this
one over here this one over here well if
this dimension if this dimension is x
plus y and that this dimension right
over here is X then this whole side or
any of the sides of the square are going
to be the sum of that so X plus X plus y
is 2 X plus y 2 X plus y you can imagine
that I'm just labeling the left side of
each of these squares the left side of
this square has length Y left side of
this One X this one has X plus y and
this is 2x plus y and then we can go to
this one up here well if this distance
right over here is 2x plus y and this
distance right over here is X plus y you
add them together to get then to get the
entire dimension of one side of the
square so it's going to be 3x 3x plus 2y
3x plus 2y I've just added the 2x plus
the X and the y plus the Y to get 3x
plus 2y is the length of one dimension
or one side of the square and they're
all the same now let's go to this next
square well if this length is 3x plus 2y
and this length is 2x plus y then this
entire length right over here is going
to be 5x 5x plus 3y 5x plus 3y is going
to be that entire length right over
there and we can also go to this this
side right over here where we have we
have this length let me do that same
color this length is 3 X plus 2 y this
is X plus y and this is y so if you add
3x plus 2y plus X plus 1
Plus y-you get 4x plus what is that 4y
right - I 3 y 4 y + 4 y + 4 y and then
we can express this character's
dimensions in terms of x and y because
this is going to be 5x plus 3y then
you're going to have 2x plus y and then
you're going to have X so you add the
X's together 5x plus 2x is 7 X plus X is
8 X 8x and then you add the Y's together
3y plus y and then you don't have a y
there so that's going to be plus 4y
that's the dimensions of this square and
then finally we have this square right
over here it's dimensions are going to
be the Y plus the 4x plus 4y so that's
4x plus 5y 4x plus 5y and then if we if
we think about the dimensions if we
think about the dimensions of this of
this perimeter of this actual rectangle
over here if we think about this 1 over
if we think about its height if we think
about its height right over there that's
going to be it's going to be 5x plus 3y
times a plus 8x plus 4y so 5 plus 8 is
13 so 13 X plus 3 plus 4 is 7 y plus 7 Y
so that's its height but we can also
think about its height by going on the
other side of it and maybe this will
give us some useful constraints because
this is going to have to be the same
length as this over here and so if we
add 4x + 4 X we get 8x we get 8x and
then if we add 4y + 5 y we get 9 y + 9 y
so these are going to have to be equal
to each other so that's an interesting
constraint so we have 13 x + 7 y + 7 Y
is going to be is going to have to equal
8 X + 9 y 8x + 9 y 8x + 8 X + 9 Y and we
can simplify this if you subtract 8x
from both sides you get 5x and if you
subtract 7 Y from both sides you get 5x
is equal to 2y
five X is equal to two Y or you could
say X is X is equal to two over five Y
in order for these to show up as
integers we have to pick integers here
but let's see if we have some of any
other interesting constraints if we look
at the bottom and the top of this if
this gives us any more information
so if we add 5x + 3 y + 3 X + 2 y + 4 X
+ 4 y this top dimension 5 plus 3 is 8
plus 4 is 12 you get 12 X 12 X 12 X and
then you get 3 y + 2 y + 4 y so that's 5
+ 4 that's 9 y + 9 y that's this top
dimension and if you go down here you
have 8 plus 4 is 12 X let me do that
same color 12 X 12 X and then your 4
plus 5 is 9 y + 9 y so these actually
ended up to be the same in terms of x
and y so they're not giving us any more
information no more constraints
obviously 12 X + 9 y is going to be
equal to 12x + 9 y so our only
constraint on this problem is what we
got by setting this this left-hand side
to this right-hand side is that X is
needs to be equal to 2/5 Y so let's just
pick some numbers so that we get nice
integers 4 x + y and then we figure out
the perimeter we want to make sure that
the the dimensions have don't have any
common divisors so if we pick if we pick
Y to be 5 if we pick Y to be 5
let's pick Y to be equal to 5 then
looking at this constraint what is X
well then X is 2 is going to be 2/5
times 5 so then X is equal to 2 so let's
see what we get for the dimensions of
this rectangle then so the height of
this rectangle is going to be let's see
13 times 2 is 26 plus 7 times 5 is 35 so
26 plus 35 gets us what that gets us to
61 this is equal to 61 did I do that
right
you see - 55 + 6 is 61 and then when you
look at the when you look at its width
you have 12 X which is 24 plus 9 Y Y is
5 so plus 45
plus 45 24 plus 45 is what that is 69 is
equal to 69 and 61 and 69 do not share
any any common divisors other than one
so it looks like we're done or we're
almost done we know the dimensions of
the rectangle it is a 61 by 69 rectangle
and if you want its actual perimeter you
just add them all up so the perimeter
here is going to be you can have a
drumroll now the perimeter is going to
be 61 plus 69 plus 61 plus 69 which is
equal to well 61 plus 69 is 130 130
that's another 130 right there 130 plus
130 is 200 260 so it actually wasn't too
bad of a problem if we just started at
the middle and just built up from there
built up the dimensions in terms of the
dimensions of these two smallest these
two smallest
squares and then we're able to find that
find the perimeter